We saw with our thought experiment in space that our two astronauts with no gravity
or any forces acting on them couldn't distinguish between motion and rest.
Now we're ready to learn Newton's First Law of Motion.
Remember our space example.
We saw our two astronauts  with no forces acting on them,
because there was no gravity in our empty universe.
They couldn't distinguish between motion in a straight line at constant speed
and being at rest.
On the train we saw that there was absolutely no experiment that we could do
which could distinguish between being at rest and traveling at a constant speed.
Newton took these kind of thoughts and formulated his first law,
which states that every object will always continue in its state of rest
or constant velocity motion, unless it's acted on by an external force.
Now, you may be saying to yourself, "What about an apple on the ground?"
Surely, that's an object at rest, but it's gravity pulling down on it?
Well, the answer to both of your questions is, yes, it is at rest,
and, yes, gravity still is pulling down.
This is a very interesting question and one that we're going to cover a little bit later in the unit.
Stay tuned to find out what's going on here.